it's now my pleasure to introduce dr.
Edward Reuben the alumni professor of
environmental engineering and science
and professor of engineering and public
policy and mechanical engineering dr.
Reuben is among the recipients of the
Nobel Peace Prize that was presented to
Vice President Al Gore and the UN
intergovernmental panel of climate
change in December of 2007 dr. Reuben
served as a lead author and coordinating
lead author author of a special report
which pointed the world toward a
workable solution to the critical
problem of global climate change he is
the first Carnegie Mellon faculty member
to share the Nobel Peace Prize we have
invited him to join us on stage today to
recognize his outstanding achievement
and to introduce our keynote speaker dr.
Reuben
Thank You Provost omelette for those
kind words first for the benefit of
those of you who may not know of the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change let me simply say that it
includes many hundreds of scientists and
experts throughout the world who have
been studying the problem of global
warming for over two decades and who
have now concluded with a high degree of
scientific certainty that human
activities indeed are changing our
climate at an unprecedented and
dangerous rate all of us involved in the
IPCC of course were extremely pleased
and proud to see this large collective
effort acknowledged by the Nobel Prize
Committee last fall but in recognizing
the accomplishments and profound impacts
of a single individual there is only one
Nobel laureate on this platform today
and it is my privilege and honor to
introduce him to you by my count this is
Al Gore's third visit to the Carnegie
Mellon campus the first was in april of
nineteen ninety two when then-senator
Gore gave the keynote speech at a
symposium here to honor of the late
Senator John Heinz and inaugurate the
newly named Hein school of public policy
and management it was a truly
spellbinding talk about the threat of
global warming passionate eloquent and
powerfully well informed eight years
later as Vice President Al Gore returned
to Carnegie Mellon during his campaign
for the presidency that October
afternoon he stood at the steps of
hamerschlag Hall and spoke to a sea of
students faculty and staff assembled on
that lawn and while we spoke of many
things that day the growing threat of
climate change was again a prominent
concern and he had the courage to level
with us that meeting that challenge
would not be easy or fast but he also
inspired us that day he inspired us to
see that a response to this problem
would unleash a massive wave of talent
and ingenuity that would create new jobs
and new industries that would not only
transform our environmental legacy but
foster economic growth as well that
vision and that message was a true act
of political courage and leadership and
then there's the movie and inconvenient
truth which I suspect many of you here
have already had a chance to see because
of that great film as best I can tell Al
Gore has become the first person in the
history of the world to receive not only
the Nobel Peace Prize but also an
Academy Award president cone ladies and
gentlemen let me introduce Vice
President Al Gore
you